so this is between richer ready which is
one of the famous hyper-modern strategy
type of players in the 20s 30s and he
was one of the best players in the world
for short he was never actually a world
championship caliber but he was close it
was not very far but he was not very far
below Capablanca or le oaken when they
were world champions he was by far one
of the strongest competitors in everyone
other tournaments so this term is
specifically is baden-baden in 1925 and
black is a world champion or I guess not
yet now yeah world champion Alexandre
yoking which you guys might know as Alec
kind also an American pronunciation of
his name and we have a very interesting
position here can anybody take a couple
minutes tell me what more or less is
going on in the position where are both
sides headed what should black play it's
black the move by the way where are the
advantages and disadvantages for every
for both sides white has very clear
pressure in which sector of the board
the Queen side right he has a queen
there he has a knight on c5 it's easy
for him as as was mentioned to bring the
rook either to the D file or the C file
and start really badgering those pawns
on the Queen side on the other hand it's
not so clear just yet where black is
going to attack right I mean he does
have an extra pawn in the Queen side but
if anything it's a weakness I cannot
really use it at the moment every move
that I make with my pawns weakens them a
little bit more so for example if I were
to simply play the move b6 I could move
the knight pretty much anywhere let's
on v3 because why not and then this pawn
starts becoming a little bit weak I
cannot push it because there's a knight
hanging on d5
and immediately trying to take the pawn
bad things are happening yes so I cannot
really kick out the Knights as easily as
I would like to so I have to think of
something else
an eloheem comes up with a very clever
idea counter-attacking is usually a good
way of deterring your opponent's plans
in this case specifically I cannot
really attack on the center although I
have a nice amount of pressure but
because of the control over the e-file
like that does cut the border can't even
half I can focus on the Kings side here
although black doesn't have many
resources there yet a Jochen is going to
show how easy it is to send them over in
that direction and the first thing is
that White's position is way too solid
in the Kings side to do anything
it must be loosened up a little bit
before I attempt to even attack on that
side so the first move is h5 so here
black played h5 with the idea that
simply I'm going to play h4 if white
replies h4 themselves they've already
given themselves a weakness
they've already at least weakened the g3
points slightly and we'll see later that
this is actually going to be a big deal
what Rati says is well you're going to
weaken my g3 pawn why do I have to waste
my own time weakening it you waste your
time and weaken it yourself there is no
danger of the h-file actually being an
issue so it's not like the H file needs
to remain closed ready said hey let's do
this B for threatening obviously
expansion on the Queen side rather
quickly a six was played a little bit
slowly you do not want to rush things
when you don't have them these gains
black an important temple because after
a4 which was not what was played but
after a four there is no threat of b5
notice that I can simply take on b5 and
this rook on a one would be hanging core
so this doesn't apply yet ready played
rook c1 keeping up the pressure on this
on the Queen side and now you can go
ahead and plate h4 now there are many
ways of dealing with an attack you can
either panic and try to beat it back as
quickly as possible
you could set up a solid defense or you
can tell it well I don't really care
go ahead all three of those options are
valid depending on the position
sometimes you do need to panic and react
as quickly as possible sometimes you
need to solidify your position slowly to
prevent any kind of attack and sometimes
this attacks just don't work and all you
have to do is ignore them and they'll go
away by themselves we call it what's
called the pseudo attack in this case
ready opts for the ladder he decides
this attack is not going to go anywhere
he decides to quite simply ignore it and
say hey you don't have any real threats
prove them to me so the game becomes a
little bit sharp a 4 was played and now
takes of course takes and the move Queen
c7 and very normal developing move
because in essence you are targeting
that square that I just weakened right
because g3 is weakened
ergo what has been weakened the King
sights yes but which squares
specifically that I can use as a
catapult to launch the rest of my attack
a ch3 and f3 are specifically weak
squares although f3 at the moment is
firmly in whites control there is one
particular square that has been weakened
indirectly by the advance of the H point
the H point Tok Tok and now g3 is weak
right because it doesn't have two
defenders there is only one defender of
g3 right so f2 is the only defender of
g3 but f2 right now is in charge of
another square III so it's possible that
in some variations this e3 Square will
be overloaded if the pawn must keep
guard over fe3 and g3
in some cases I might even consider
sacrificing my knight so ready looks at
the position says what else goes b5 and
that probably was not exactly the
correct response here probably he should
have played efore taking out the knight
from the center and then a 5 he didn't
really want to do this because it kind
of locks the Queen side but at the same
time his position on the Kings side is
much much safer now that I played efore
tactics fail 493 does not so is it not
so hard to calculate 93 first of all I
don't have a threat so I can just move
it in the queen and then this night is
completely trapped on e3 right I don't
you have to deal with Oh what happens if
he takes on g3 with Czech blah blah blah
okay this is over the knight doesn't
have any rescue so he instead played the
move b5 just continuing on his attack
and now we start thinking about
candidate moves everybody here familiar
with candidate moves right so what can
we come up with now top of the top of
your head let's count the removes you
just think whatever you come up with you
don't have to calculate it doesn't have
to work it doesn't even have to be smart
93 good 93 s1 what else
a texture ah yes he takes you could play
see text correct nothing wrong with that
move that I can see not immediately
complain 94 but I think it's defended
twice right there's a bishop on each one
which is quite key anything else are we
out of ideas
ah it might be six but ah not h5 maybe
to try to take on g3 right anything else
all right let's stop for one second the
open your da file who does that favor
right now block because there's a
recording area we think no further we
open the a file and then we start
calculating again so we already said
some moves right so let's turn them
apart little by little now the first
problem with Knight b6 I think was
mentioned which is by the mean by all
means none of these moves are bad thank
you computer
none of these moves are bad but they
lack precision and in this case is where
the game is so sharp usually you need a
heavy dose of precision to survive the
night although it attacks the Queen on
c4 is not really participating in the
attack on the kingside so it looks a
little unnatural to move back if I must
play this it's probable it's probable
that White's reasoning of ignoring your
King side advances were correct so what
else could I play I could play 93
correct however you have to realize that
your opponent is not as helpful as you
want them to be this happens in about
100 percent of the chess games and you
cannot really count on him taking on e3
because okay it's true that after taking
on g3 Bishop g2 Bishop h3 it is already
impossible for him to stop the maid on
g2 in a comfortable
and King f1 is no better because I still
play Bishop h3
however rarity being one of the best
players in the world will probably just
smirk enough and move the Queen away
probably to d3 and then it is entirely
unclear what your Knight is doing on e3
it's not that it's being threatened
there is no threat of F take c3
it's more along the lines of well what
what is your knight doing there right so
another possibility is to directly play
Knight h5 correct this unfortunately
runs into a couple of ideas the first
and foremost which I will be most
worrying about is to simply take on d5
take on d5 and Queen takes d5 so at this
point I have destroyed this powerful
defensive Bishop but at the same time
this queen is now comfortably going to
come back to the defense and it's not so
clear now how I'm going to continue so
we must keep coming up with moves
because when everything fails we try
something different rule of thumb you
cannot dwell on moves that you refute it
simply so do we have any new alternative
C yes okay how would you start doing
this
very good so we start thinking about
moves like rookie 7 and the idea of
rookie 7 is you bring the other route
can suddenly okay I have some pressure
in the kingside however it's a little
bit slow right at the same time we have
to consider what is white going to do
and well I'm not so worried about
pushing upon me I'm more worried about
him taking taking and moving the knight
back and then this guy is quite soft yes
so not so hot and in this kind of
positions we think hey white is playing
B takes c6 and he's annihilating my King
side in my queen side and about two
moves right and best-case scenario I
will suffer for a draw this happens
because maybe I can hold it okay called
upon sir in the King side blah blah blah
but the truth is that this already looks
quite ugly if I let him let him do this
so I have to come up with something
quick if I cannot actually find
something yes ah sorry we have the idea
of group very good
rook a3 the idea being to take the pawn
yes boom you take the pawn and hey
there's real threats this is not a Roop
you can ignore I cannot take on g3 and
be like ah the rooks there whatever kind
of like what I did with the night no
this is a real threat if I take on c6
immediately rook takes g3 check takes
check Bishop g2 93 and it's over
notice how not only is g2 not defensible
which is not but the knight is attacking
the Queen which in many cases simply
makes it a fork but even without the
fork in existence there is also already
completely wind because you cannot
defend the bishop on g2 so this would be
awesome rook a3 BAM attacking the pawn
on g3 excellent everything's going our
way but again this jerk that's white
actually doesn't let me do what I want
to do so remember that we were talking
about pawn takes pawn takes Knight back
and this pawn is really soft how about
if he does it the other way around now
my rook is out of play because of the
powerful Knight and b3 blocking it
I'm threatening the potency 6 which is
actually just part of what I wanted to
do salami no no help
ah now we have an idea
Luke III so after rook e3 first of all
is the pawn Oh does the rook hanging can
I take it absolutely not for the same
reason we just saw takes takes near
takes same thing right no no danger like
an attorney take on G 2 1 G 2 and G 3
you cannot block with the night on B 3
because I have my roof on the e-file so
he must think of something Knight f3 was
actually rich already spoken move can we
actually come up with any other ideas
bash up f3 might be better let's think
why would it be better why would it be
worse
that's very true
it does defend the et porn which became
quite a weakness in this game so Bishop
at three it was a from what I remember
the correct continuation Bishop takes f3
pawn takes f3 and now it is not so clear
how white black continues it's possible
that he's a little bit worse this was
quite good now let's analyze Bishop g2
what about this move
I mean it's logical because now after
rook takes three three point eight three
three Queen takes you three that's not
check yeah everybody happy with this so
we're black do I am threatening the rook
now so let's calculate a little bit any
ideas
what is the first thing you have to look
at does it work on 93 yes what's wrong
with Queen takes
can white play an awesome defensive
route d 393 anyways it's still a little
dangerous but maybe I can bring some the
route to the defense anyways
you could play route d3 but after ninety
three I think
okay you're up a piece but your king is
quite exposed I think this is no problem
for black know something else well
there's a nice defending on c3 right so
you cannot really play this so we want
to bring this rook to the defense
doesn't mean that it has to be in the
3rd rank very good now e4 so if you move
the knife to e3 which is what he wanted
to do all along by the way if Queen
check you simply cover there's no
problems if you play 93 well I go Quinn
d3 I'm pretty much chill what's the
problem here
you cannot take because of the pin and
even if there was no pin I can simply
retake back so nothing to do here for
black however I could move things around
and block the pawn first forcing the
Queen to move and there is no way that
this Queen in the next move can defend
the bishop obviously it cannot defend
the pawn right so the Queen g3 will be
the next move everybody clear with that
one there is no way this Queen will come
back to defend the bishop so it's
already lost after this move or whatever
Queen d3 Queen g3 and it's over no way
to defend equip the bishop right
remember I was telling you guys that it
didn't matter that it was a fork or not
here the pressure on g2 is sufficient to
win by itself so mission g2 no bueno
what about King h2
I obviously cannot capture on g3 because
it's defended right I don't have enough
support in that position which is quite
unfortunate I could try to play Knight
h5 but it doesn't work for several
reasons so no not h5 I want to keep
putting pressure on g3 how can I do this
it's a move that was already suggested
I'm very good ok three
now after pawn takes Knight takes he
could play Knight cb3 but this actually
runs into some problems now sorry oh we
can't go through every variation but
here this typical idea doesn't quite
work so let's analyze what happens if he
takes right I mean this should be the
crucial question well the point here is
that after Knight takes c3 I'm
threatening the Queen yeah Queen
somewhere and check if I take with the
rook Queen g3 is checkmate yes
if Queen g1 Queen takes g3 King takes f1
or Bishop g2 whatever 93 we know this
motive winning yes so ready sees all
this decides I need to protect g3 and
decides to do it with the knight to
retain his structure okay a yoking must
continue his initiative but what else
can the dead moose let's go back to
basics what do you always have to
consider
Justin captures yes what capture do you
have here
well but okay you lose the rook for no
apparent reason also trading on f3 with
the bishop okay doesn't seem to
accomplish too much
no I capture that well just a capture
see take some b5 yes yeah interesting it
distracts the Queen for one second so we
have to decide because the point what
would be the point of this move like
what did I gain is there any particular
square that I gained access to 93 makes
more sense okay so now 93 gets the
knight out of where we wanted it to be
it was vulnerable and d5 right because
we wanted to play 94 and it attacks the
Queen attacking Queen sir is awesome
because it'll move them I take them and
it allows me put to put a knight on e4
because even if it's traded off then
anyways I'm going to have a knight there
so ready it's like whatever I'm going to
take your pawn so he does now there's
not that much of a choice black plays I
guess there was a choice because you
guys are coming up with moose well 92
Czech has the problem that I think
that's right 92 transposes from what I
remember but first they took on b7
notice that the queen is hanging so I
cannot really move the rook right so
Queen takes b7 and I take the side and
now 92 Chuck so we continue our
wonderful calculations the game is
symmetrical in the sense that there are
two points on the Queen side against two
points on the Kings side but blacks
initiative is not over what is an utter
an unpleasant juncture where can he move
the knight sorry the king he cannot take
only two because I just take the rook
right I'm up the exchange with excellent
winning chances probably just winning
so I have three alternatives one losers
immediately which one is it what is the
most ridiculous of them all well that is
not that ridiculous what is wrong with
king of one Bishop h3 is not checkmate I
have a chip g2 so that doesn't lose
anything what about King G - that's
pretty bad because after King G - I am
able to simply play Bishop takes f3
check and you just lost the piece for
free so I have I'm down to two moves
yeah so the first one is not so hard to
refute the first one is King f1 so I
have to think how do I continue in this
position with black I cannot take here
because pawn takes Bishop takes King
takes and after Bishop takes b7 I emerge
up a little bit of material and although
the winning chances are not great but
white again is not going to be that nice
against Bishop takes f3 he can first
take on f3 and if rook takes f3 then I
can take the knight yeah if you take
some c1 I take only 3 and this is equal
material so this doesn't make any sense
and we have a position that is not so
good for black so we have to come up
with something else we have to use that
power of calculation to come up with
different way of playing this position
one of the first things we look at in
calculation checks and and what's more
awesome than a check or a capture it's a
check and the capture so
check distracting the pond because now
there is no nobody's taking any three so
I feel free to take this guy right so
now black white is forced to trade off
the bishops and this is nearly hopeless
because after King G to Luke a3 I'm
going to win this pond too so it's not
that just done one point you're down two
points and your knight on b7 is quite
hilariously bad and on top of that your
King is quite exposed right whereas
white blacks King is quite comfortably
safe not good for white so not this
Reddy was relying on King H - yeah no
choice King H - so here comes a little
bit of I would say although his magic
when he was playing chess he had a way
with pieces that is difficult to
perceive especially for people back in
the age so there are several candidate
moves what do we have to analyze here
Bishop takes Knight is the first what
else
okay the other rook to a3 but there are
so many things hanging right now that I
don't think I can give up a temple like
this right rook takes night good what
else Knight takes rook right anything
else that a good stopping point all
right so first off Bishop f3 if Bishop
f3
okay I can take it I think now candidate
moves only two I can take the bishop
where I can take the rook right if you
take the bishop I take your knight and
this looks pretty equal to me right we
can sign a peace treaty and go to
Starbucks or something and it's over
because pushing this game is no it makes
no sense if you take here after pawn
takes c3 all you really did was put your
knight in an ugly situation and okay all
the white structure is not the best he's
not really in any danger of losing this
position so after king h2 we have to
think okay what if Knight c1 but not c1
also kind of deals pawn takes c3 and
again material is even and blacks
advantage is nowhere to be found yes
again a very slight structural advantage
but with such few pieces on the board
it's kind of hard to come up with
anything so a Lohan comes up with a very
pretty move in this position with the
knight with the rook on e3 hanging he
simply brings another piece to the
attack so there's somebody here that
wants to join the fray who could it be
oh by the way we also said rook F 3
right and we didn't analyze it okay so
after rook F 3 rookie 2 actually black
doesn't have any particularly good
discoveries with the rook all he can
really do is play rook f5 which is the
best move but rugby 2 cancels this idea
the idea of rook f5 was kind of like if
you move randomly then check
here takes takes check force the King in
the night but even that is not so great
for for black and that there's nothing
really important here so rook b3 the
bishop is still defending the knight
right so there's no no danger you could
try to take only three on g3 since this
is a attacked but with such reduced
material it is very unlikely that you
can win this position if we find nothing
better this might be the best
continuation but this is already not so
easy to win there's only one extra pawn
and there are so few pawns left that
making a chart a draw should be
relatively trivial for white in this
position especially at that level so the
only looks like this chances tries to
figure out hey what else can I do and he
comes up with the move Knight e4 so take
a couple of minutes and try to figure
out what on earth is the point of ninety
four right
but calculation wise what's the
difference I mean I already had a rook
to take why am i throwing another one
this is a very specific chest this is
the art of calculation this is what we
call very absolute ideas very exact you
have to calculate precisely because
general concepts have been thrown
overboard right here it's all about
calculation there is already a threat
right which is right but let's say the
rooks get swapped then what would be the
the tempo that I already have a threat
here with black that I did not execute
but I did have a threat which was I mean
we looked at the candidate moves right
which was like the biggest material gain
that I could do in one move yeah and I
think c1 so the idea was that I'm taking
on c1 the rook is not moving in this
variation so it's still hanging at the
end and you have this idea of Knight x
f3 so Y cannot meet both right
that doesn't mean that red is out of the
game yet so after 94 the first things
first if rook da check what happened
the idea is to jettison the rook so
after takes obviously not Knight takes
here because among many winning ideas
are Knight takes F - Bishop takes f3
even knight take c1 is sufficient for an
advantage but okay maybe not 90 c1 root
cap 3 is also quite good
pretty much anything especially not f2
is already quite powerful so black a
white must must recapture on e3 right to
safeguard a pawn and now comes a
brilliant idea root d5 VI concept that
the attack has not ended despite the
fact that material is so reduced notice
how beautifully blacks pieces completely
control whites there is no rook c8 Chuck
because there's a bishop on g4 there is
no rook c5 because this Knight is
defending the square and I'm immediately
threatening rook h5 check let's say that
we make a random move to defend the rook
well we actually have to make a random
if to the front of rook right and let's
put it here whatever so the problem is
that now suddenly Chuck is an issue if
you play Knight h4 I play Knight g3 and
who's going to defend this guy nobody
right if you go
King G - I go check
you have to go back and then I go check
not bad right after work the five I
think we like what is completely lost so
he cannot play roopd a check what else
can he do he could try f2x III but this
one is very easily refuted by what we
just saw Knight takes D to and now I am
training both 9 takes f3 check and I'm
threatening Knight take c1 so black
emerges at the very least up the
exchange enough to win so Reddy's a
little bit more cunning than that he
plays rook c4 I move that probably all
of you saw and obviously already refuted
so what's the point here well the point
is actually quite interesting if you
take on d2 then I simply take back and
now who is the one that's under double
attack there is a problem with the rook
and the bishop yes so what if black says
whatever rook t3 I'm attacking your
knight right then ready uses a very
interesting idea kind of the same as
other allele him just did he doesn't
execute his threat he creates a new one
night c5 attacking that rook on d3 but
who else am i attacking a 8 so I win a
rook at most you when I get a piece back
so I get my exchange back and it's equal
therefore a yoking after rook c4 did not
take on d2 he also cannot take on f3
oops
take on f3 with the bishop the point of
this move would be that if pawn takes
simply Knight takes D to right ends up
in a winning position because if we
count the pieces I'm up 1 meaning up a
piece is awesome this is not good for
white so the idea was that here Reddy
had a brill
- move rook takes e4 if rook takes e4
Bishop takes f3 there is a double attack
on the rock of the night best-case
scenario you move back I take and I take
an equality if you take with the bishop
then pawn takes a three Bishop takes h1
King takes h19 takes g3 check King G -
this is not easy to win at all again we
have a scenario and when there's two
pawns against one but because of the
reduced amount of pawns it's not easy to
crash through remember that any end game
that's rook and Knight against rook is
drawn and it's actually not so difficult
to hold rook and Bishop against rook is
difficult to hold rook at night against
rook and not that hard I mean it's not
like I'm not going to test you on it if
I ever get the position but it is
probably not going to happen so on the
other side say I'm going to continue the
attack Oh
he plays Knight takes F - guess who gets
an extra pawn and defense the bishop
yeah all important things no immediate
threat at the moment except for
what's-what's blacks only threat right
now
well the immediate Roque one would would
turn in the threat right but something
immediate right away
well Bishop takes Knight does not mean a
piece because I take it back
and if rook takes f3 rook takes c2 the
Knights hanging at the end right so
that's not an immediate threat what is
an immediate threat
well who's defining the night right this
is the threat so I'm threading Knight
takes H to negative takes h1 sorry so
why needs to figure out something to do
if I move the knight I simply take on h1
and then take on g3 right there should
be no doubt about that that's 2 extra
points to is good one is not so Bishop
g2 only move and now does the attack die
off because there is no material and the
answer is no I must continue the
initiative if you play some passive move
like rook somewhere or whatever it's
very possible that white simply
organizes a defense and again you're
only up one pony and with a reduced
amount of them it's very difficult to
convert so tempo moves I would like to
check this guy somehow right but I
cannot bring my rook into activity very
easily actually it's very difficult to
do so I have to figure out something and
I figure hey my knight they kind of
their kind of bad actually they're both
in the e-file and if I move either one
of them it's going to get taken right so
let's start moving them away Bishop e6
the point is that I'm clearing the g4
check sorry the g4 square with check and
of course it's the temple move I'm
running the rook right rook must move
rook CC 2 makes tons of sense because
now these guys are not so happy right
so check and now King h3 if King H 1
simply Knight takes G 3 I'm up a two
pawns right actually actually wreck a
one might be
longer yeah I'm going to go with Roque
one is even stronger first and then this
is kind of collapsing so he has to go to
h3 and brave through the discovery but
where's the discovery what's going on
the knight doesn't have any particularly
good checks
I could go Knight f2 back King H -
that's a draw
I could go to e5 but then I have to
calculate and where else can I go
there is no particularly strong
discovery that's immediate right so the
Orion actually comes up with a very
clever very pretty pretty long
combination
he plays 95 check first KH 2 and takes
with the rook what's up with that so
first things first if you take simply
Knight f3 check then I recover my
exchange and I'm up one piece which we
determine is awesome so now rook f3 no
no Bishop f3 here you must take the
night but that recovers the night right
and now I have a double attack this guy
on this guy so 94 back King h3 again
forced if I go back to g1 there is the
issue of taking and there's also the
issue of the background quiche with rook
a 1 right so no choice to hit for him
brave it up King age 3 check on e3
no no choice King h2 and I take so I'm
up the rook right but Reddy's like I'm
gonna get that rook back so we're still
equal material except for the pawn right
and now so what was the point
well he forked the pieces now what's the
only defense for white Yama must play
the rook defending the Bishop right
doesn't matter
rook F to trade trade so what's the
point I mean I mean I'm in a position
wrap a pawn but whatever the endgame is
difficult to win but at the very end
Bishop d5 threatening the rook oops
starting the rook the bishop perfectly
controls the only square where the rook
could defend the night and attacks the
night this was actually for white and
for black all force from this position
Bishop e6 only move Roxy to check only
move King edge 395 check route takes f3
only move rook taxi to check only move
King h3 check only move king h2 takes
takes 94 only move rook f2 actually
doesn't make a difference rook F to a
rookie 3 takes take special defy little
crown jewel in the list of violent
attacks by a Leo keen in chess and to be
fair this was one of his most violent
attacks without a queen the queen that
got traded off relatively quickly so I
mean when it comes to calculation these
guys are awesome
the only difference is that nowadays
they don't get the chance as often to
execute combinations like this the thing
is that players are so advanced that you
know whoever richer red is equal is
nowadays he would have seen it in
advance and not let this happen